priorité à l'info sur wk paix news un
objet venu du ciel se serait écrasé
je viens d'appeler
il a besoin de toi
tu viens d'arriver et et la plage fait
profil bas
hall de pointe-claire qu'est ce qui a
disparu qui se passe des choses étranges
un soir mans dans la forêt
j'ai vu un
tu as une idée de ce que ça a même que
toi non
j'ai jamais vu ça
oh [ __ ] les mecs
premier contact
s'est fait peur je peux vous demander
qui vous est
peut être aussi méfier des flics
certains témoins il ya eu des
enlèvements disent pas la vérité
ce qui arrive vers goût est
incontrôlable
je serai pas
lentement
ça existe
nos billets enfin un sens est en train
de passer pour un fou du roi mois
[Musique]
hu
vous pensez pas qu'il faudrait qu'on
prévienne l'armée
[Musique]